going outside can be dangerous these
days a poisonous cloud of dust has
settled over the 20 million inhabitants
of the metropolis many fear than in the
coming weeks the smog will be the worst
it's ever been some are getting us
through our thoughts some are getting
heart attacks right now this is
sickening in delhi's a lot of pollution
because of day by day of car sorry are
increasing you can literally see the
smoke in the air and if I take a deep
breath I can also smell it and this is
just the beginning of winter and Delhi
so if you take a look at the AQI this
morning we have a value of 450 almost
this is hazardous and that means
dangerous and it is 20 times higher than
the recommendations of the World Health
Organization these volunteers hope they
can make a difference they're working
with an NGO to visit Delhi schools and
teach children how to protect themselves
from acute smog half of the Capitals
children already suffer from breathing
problems children are also learning
what's making the air so poisonous and
what they can do about it
yeah evolution for me it was like
terrible since last few days because I
having an allergic person was feeling
like condition and you know I was
feeling burned in my IV spread awareness
about about to the people that we should
not pull you there as it's a it's a
vetting awesome we cannot go out when we
move out into it is becoming a problem
too many cars burning garbage and large
construction sites many factors
contribute to the smog clear action is
necessary but comment bodies slid little
you know they're not waking up
completely so because this is an
emergency they have to take some harsh
steppes also cuz they should be you know
coming up very fast otherwise we'll be
too late those who can afford it are
getting ready for the smog season masks
and air filters have become hot items
I'm on Mike always and I'm already like
coughing so someone I can feel the
congestion here so I think it's better
to have one that string goes on you're
around eight years and I wear a turban
so that's not possible you know yeah I'm
a little worried because they quite warm
looking you know like it's like in this
weather wearing a mask doesn't reduce
the pollution but at least it gives
people a feeling they're doing something
positive for their health